as world leaders meet in Bali they were
greeted by a leader who usually shies
away from Global diplomacy to focus more
on issues closer to home now as the war
in Ukraine takes its toll on the global
economy including developing countries
like Indonesia djokovodoto took his
place on the world stage with a warning
for his fellow leaders off the G20
responsible here awesome means
that we must end the war if the war does
not end it will be difficult for the
world to move forward
it's the first time the group has met
since the Russian invasion
as many countries around the world
struggle with rampant inflation and
Rising food and energy costs many say
the two crises cannot be separated
we've got chaos in energy markets we've
got issues in food security you know
clearly the Russian aggression in
Ukraine is the source of that or most of
the source of that Ukrainian
presidentski addressed the leaders
virtually appealing to them to work
towards extending a deal which allows
grain and other food commodities blocked
at Ukrainian ports by Russian ships to
be exported the original Arrangement is
said to expire in coming days I believe
our export grain initiative deserves an
indefinite extension no matter when the
war ends Russian President Vladimir
Putin is not attending the summit
sending his foreign minister in his
place
all problems are with the Ukrainian side
which is categorically refusing
negotiations and putting forward
conditions that are obviously
unrealistic and do not correspond to the
situation
the host of The Summit Indonesia has
repeatedly called for Unity throughout
its G20 presidency in the Hope members
can focus on the global economic
recovery rather than what divides them
and put aside tensions for the sake of
the people they represent
in a meeting with the French leader
China's president Xi Jinping said the
world has entered a new period of
turbulence and transformation it's a
message that has been echoed throughout
this month of diplomacy in Asia While
most leaders can agree the world faces
many challenges achieving consensus on
how to navigate those difficulties is
where their differences lie Jessica
Washington altazira Bali